[Music]
all right this one's a real serious one
so try not to laugh don't you can't
start with that
why not all i want to do is laugh now
well well good luck laughing at this
good luck man there was an arizona
elementary school fundraiser right
that's funny
actually that is kind of funny
raising funds good luck kids
so they're um they're doing a fundraiser
event they hired a dj
and then uh the these diversity
activists that were at the fundraiser
filed a complaint why was there a
diversity activist at a children's
fundraiser because you got to have them
every time you do anything they're going
to be there so like there's
so there's like there's there's kids
like picking out there like there's
[ __ ] third graders like well these
are i think they're adults that work
like they're part of the pta yeah but
the imagery of a third grader
being a diversity activist is much
better yeah with a little science
changing the change article
elementary school in vietnam
here here's the uh
here's the thing i don't like it i like
it now here's the real story because
it's i've made fun of enough i'm going
to get canceled now yeah so
the dj for the event was uh
accused of performing in blackface what
wait what
why is he so that's why the diversity
people showed up that's why they filed
the complaint they're like what the [ __ ]
is happening here why would this dj be
blackface we have to find reasons why he
would do this would he like [ __ ] dude
because it wasn't it was like techno but
they all they wanted me to do hip-hop so
i got to play my part
and then they went full-on blackface
that might make sense the event was a
70s scene
and so this guy like the dj guy like got
into his his like caution and stuff here
i'll show you guys
oh did you have an afro
of course
this guy like got accused for
wait he looks wait what that's him
what's his ethnicity he's not black
he is black
wait what
shut up
so
white people accused a black guy for
black facing not only that it was a
white lady and a black dude accused him
of throwing egg in blackface
but he's just a black dude so what was
his response cause i was like that
makeup was [ __ ] good yeah like i was
like that's really good
that might be the best black face i've
ever seen because i'm like that's
acceptable black face if it's that good
dude that's top tier that's s tier
[ __ ] black face hollywood can't even
do that [ __ ]
so this guy his name's dj kim coco
hunter he's 56 and he said he was
shocked to find out about accusations he
looks like he's like 32. yeah the guy's
young as [ __ ] wow he's 50. so the second
thing is
this fundraiser was like highly
successful they raised more than 300k
for the event it looks like a funnel you
should be accused for young face
[Laughter]
jailbaiting he's jailbaiting yeah you're
jailbaiting dude yeah so these uh these
two people they filed complaints and
then uh even better what happened is
after these two uh activists filed
complaints and they were uh hit with a
response that no that dude was actually
just a black guy
um they call that racist no the guy said
he said he doubled down on his
accusation by saying well um i think
a black guy in blackface is also a
different conversation we should have no
way but what
he's an activist he thinks that dj
pretty sure the way he said it it formed
into a question like i'm pretty sure a
black guy in blackface
he didn't even believe himself the dude
who accused him is also black and he's
accusing the dj guy of
making himself even darker because he
used to be light-skinned and now he's
trying to be like me
it's i mean look at so like check this
out these are the two that that are
accusing them are they like that's him
like well what he's already played yeah
i'm like that's the dj that's the dj
that's the guy that's like you're doing
blackface yeah these are the accusers
he's just laughing is he like i can't
believe this is happening you know
what's cool he's taking it with so much
grace like they interviewed him on the
news and they're like what do you think
of them like saying this stuff and all
he kept saying was like i honestly can't
speak for them because i have no idea
like why they would say that
he's like really really cool because
this dude's like he's like a comedian
active he's like a like an all-around
like dope dude and so it's a stupid
pointless activist group that's accusing
another activist that's loved by the
community exactly
that's hilarious and this just because
this guy was decked out in 70s with afro
and roller skates bell bottoms and he
was having a great time and then all of
a sudden he's like wait i'm accused of
what that is is one of the best stories
i've ever heard
this kind of reminds me of when me and
joe used to do shows
backfires yeah when we me and joyce do
shows as the uncles right and then we
like we
we were doing it in accents and stuff
and then the asian activists would like
how can it be perpetuating these
stereotypes you do the things that we're
trying to do away with and then we're
like because we're talking like
afterward of the show you know what
don't you think that when we embrace
these stereotypes and we make people
enjoy and we love it that we're actually
like empowering the community and
they're like
and every side that me you know
i'm like they just couldn't wait to like
fear [ __ ] and then like just have their
own insecurities i think for them they
almost want to like just completely
bleach
that when asians come here their english
is perfect and they've assimilated but
there's a huge culture in the middle
that i think is super beautiful where
you're figuring [ __ ] out right you can
embrace those things too and it's
[ __ ] hilarious it's hilarious it's
dope but then you laugh at it but for
them they were just so like get that out
of here i already came here and i
already went to uc berkeley just out of
nowhere you know
oh
yeah
i don't know where yeah i don't know i
just [ __ ] 4.0 just kidding
it's so weird because it's almost like
they want validation and approval from
uh mainstream america so bad
that they want to deny the fact that
this like gray area exists with us like
the whole great parents the whole like
things that they're embarrassed about
like i'm i'm openly like laughing about
because it's like it's real like it's
the most colorful story yeah it's fun
yeah like it's a reason why we're here
too and like doing what we're doing too
like because of
them coming here yeah a movie about a
like six generation asian dude that's
boring as [ __ ] nobody wants to watch
that yeah cause that gray area is
fleeting like it's gone after yeah
you know that's so true and we're not
gonna [ __ ] unless we act like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you gotta keep
the accents alive even though it's not
real your kids are okay
i thought you were born here
keeping tradition alive
maybe that's what people say when they
wanted aquafina to sound more asian like
man you [ __ ] trying to copy black
people and [ __ ] what did they expect her
to i know
i'm the aqua guy
i hate that argument that that one was
really messed up because it's like
either sound like this or nothing at all
pick one lived in queens like most of
her life what do you want from her we
had the same uh question when we were
doing a show at stanford and we were
talking we did a q a portion and this
girl was like hey um
how come your friend david so pretends
like he's black
and i'm like
well what are you talking about i you
know like if you grew up in long beach
or like if you grew up in different
areas in america in a neighborhood
isn't white that's where you learn
english
it just so happens that you know david's
family owned the black beauty supply
store so all the english he was hearing
was from black women so it's like
obviously so he sounds like a black
woman
yeah yeah sassy sassy davis
he's always like scratching it he's
scratching his head with his palm
but i'm like isn't that natural like
isn't that how humans let's just learn
language like yeah i changed the way i
speak too because uh just you know going
to different like play like moving
around and then going to college and
[ __ ] like that like oh my english
changes right but then i didn't always
speak this way like because you know i
[ __ ] lived somewhere else and you
used to have accents
when you were younger you have access is
that you were
[Laughter]
yeah sometimes when i hear questions
like that too i was like oh this is the
dave is racist
that's a good answer and then they're
just like
because they want to have a stupid fight
for no reason they're like yeah just sit
back down you just nip it in the butt
yeah like yeah shut up dude
it sucks too because there's also like a
david sucks there's a point where it
also becomes part of survival i think
like i sounded mexican because all my
friends are mexican and if i sounded
like too like white it sounds like i'm
better than them kind of a thing and
it's almost offensive to them like if
i'm like hey can i borrow your super
nintendo game
you know
like [ __ ] did you say i talk to them
like that
people use certain lingo and people like
kind of [ __ ] on it like what does that
mean well yeah you just get you you just
get used to that [ __ ] yeah you just get
used to it after we came back from
australia right like when people were
like oh how's melbourne like i don't
want to be the [ __ ] face that's like
actually
actually it's melbourne
okay when i was in melbourne and it's
like americans don't [ __ ] pronounce
it like that they say melbourne so it's
like just [ __ ] save the way that
whoever you're talking to so you don't
have to be like actually you know i'm
the cultured one
i just got back so
let's say los angeles you know you know
what's also confusing is that like when
when you see like the like those angry
activists are like no you sound black
you're not allowed to do that but then
on the other side white people are like
learn language
like you should talk like us you know
like wait what yeah i just want to be
right here
like i'm wrong the folk side so it's
kind of funny that like that like in
popular media it looks like white people
want you to sound white if you live in
america
it's like that's confusing too they're
the ones that yell at you so what do you
want to buy yeah thank you
jesus christ it's funny because my my
original white
and a lot of original white don't
understand white
she was like it's the weirdest thing she
goes i go into starbucks or like i go
make these orders she goes it's all the
minorities that can understand my
british english yeah but white people in
america have a hard time getting it and
i'm like
yeah that's interesting
she ordered black coffee the other day
and the guy was like huh what and then
they didn't even register it because
black coffee
black come get a smidge in a black
coffee
get out of here you didn't say she used
all those turks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you